[Musique]
sa taille est fine
à gaza ces photos
s
mais
windows
[Musique]
ils vous voient quand vous dormez il
sent quand vous êtes s'éveiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il sait si vous avez été sages arrête
les enfants ne sont pas idiots ils
savent comment ça marche
pardon père noël
peggy tu regardes placement la caméra
c'est le père noël
en chair et en os une seule mi temps
[Musique]
vous ressemblez pas au père noël
les panneaux de pub ou rage ou 40 kilos
noël est en danger on peut y arriver si
on s'y met tous ensemble
j'en ai vu de choses étranges dans ma
vie mais ça attend de voir ce qui
arrivera ensuite
moi
si jamais tu rencontres la mère noël un
jour évite évite de lui raconter ça
[Musique]
vous voulez vous retrouver sur la liste
des enfants pas sages
on est d'accord alors on se remet au
boulot
[Musique]
pas du tout
jusqu'au bout
[Musique]
une antenne
madrid ap
[Musique]
c'est littéralement le pire week-end de
ma vie si nos amis du comic-con vie tu
te seras fait couper les cheveux par un
toiletteur je vais entrer au lycée lundi
avec une coupe de chiens c'est mes deux
meilleurs vanille mon plan c'est de leur
offrir le meilleur week-end de leur vie
avant d'entrer au lycée est ce lundi
mais les meilleurs souvenirs il n'est ce
pas de plan qui se déroule comme prévu
ils naissent plutôt de plans qui foire
complètement tu as mis le bazar chez moi
tu as perdu mon chien fou tu vois tu as
pris ma vie est dure mais pau comment on
peut survivre au lycée si on peut même
pas survivre à ce week end
désolé si tu trouves que je suis pas
cool j'ai dit des choses que je regrette
d'avoir dit c'est la fin c'est sûr c'est
pas la fin quand on l'a pas décidé
d'accord parce que quand la situation se
complique c'est là qu'il faut qu'on
s'applique pas j'ai un blanc je déteste
quand tu dis ça
les choses ont changé quand je suis
arrivé au lycée tulle aime d'amour non
dans la vie il faut parfois faire preuve
d'audace et volets de l'avant argonautes
cette fois ce pourrait pâtir et passe au
dessus de tous ces gosses
pour certains la situation paraît
insurmontable
pour nous tous
les membres du crh coup
c'est à dire du tout
compris les gars parce qu'il fallait que
ce soit le week-end le plus marrant de
toute attache tard est là le meilleur
week-end de ma vie le meilleur
pourquoi
[Musique]
s'il faut bien que l'homme défend
maintenant allez tiens t'as vu ton
meilleur pote mourir
maintenant tu te sens coupable mais en
fait tu dis est pour rien un service à
me demander
j'accepte attendent aborde c'est parce
que c'est pas la peine sur son toit pour
faire tomber un des nos méthodes et chef
d'un gang de bikers appelée l'île vous
ici c'est chez moi maintenant je dois
faire 2-2 ans que je cherchais et l'inde
et d'autres
là c'est pour toi oui c'est parce que tu
as tué mon lit même pas
on a perdu un frère
et à nous de le venger
aurait pu étudier pour rien
c'est pas ceux qui sont du même son
retour c'est pour qui tu es prêt à cet
ensemble
[Musique]
certaines personnes ont beaucoup de
peine sans vraiment triste de ce qui
m'est arrivé
des fois j'ai envie de pleurer mais je
me retiens des voix si choqué je pensais
pas qu'autant de gens s'intéresserait
aussi petites affaires partout dans le
monde des millions tout le monde parle
de making mère d'horreur et de la fère
steven avery ce n'est pas fini
quand quelqu'un est condamné il doit
remuer ciel et terre pour sortir de
prison
notre tâche à présent c'est d'obtenir
gain de cause par le biais d'un système
conçu pour donner l'avantagé aux
procureurs qu'est ce qu'on a envie que
la bonne personne soit condamné oui
sûrement mais c'est secondaire par
rapport au reste
elle est partie et ça on ne pourra
jamais rien n'est changé la célèbre
avocate catherine fender spécialiste des
condamnations injustifiées a repris
l'affairé habré
mon objectif est de faire annuler la
condamnation de steven avery pourquoi un
homme avour est il un crime qu'il n'a
pas commis
il voulait des aveux à tout pays les ont
pu grâce à la pire des méthodes s'est
dit si je le redis ce qu'ils veulent
entendre
[Musique]
je pourrais rentrer à la maison
selon l'accusation teresa n'a jamais
quitté la propriété d avery or son
dernier appel a été captée par une
antenne relais se trouvant à des
kilomètres de la propriété
dans 70 à 80% des cas la victime est
assassiné par quelqu'un qu'elle connaît
tous les gens doivent être considérés
comme des suspects potentiels
si beaucoup de choses reposent sur cette
balle c'est un point crucial il y à tout
un tas d'un 10 une seule preuve pourrait
remettre en question tout le faire c'est
la condamnation de dassier est annulé et
qu'un second procès commence
l'accusation aura-t-elle une chance sans
ses aveux le comté de manitowoc ne sera
mon travail mes parents soit une famille
heureuse comme avant je dois essayer de
restaurer notre bonheur je bâtirai une
grande maison on vire à tous et je
m'occuperai d'eux je veux les rendre
heureux jusqu'à la fin de leur vie c'est
ça qui me fait peur si les preuves
contre avery son solide s'il est bien
coupable
alors je jouerai
il fait deux ans que je serai pas tout
ce que je touche se transforme en échec
n'est pas david bowie papa tu sauras
jamais moi j'ai trouvé plus dépressifs
que moi j'ai l'impression que ma qualité
le film je suis alcoolique ce qui m'a
sauvé c'est mon équipe de natation
synchronisée masculine aussi prometteuse
je veux dire un point dans cette équipe
est connue la volonté la grâce loris tu
es une grande hygiène de vie
tu te sens capable de ça bon tu sais
nager au moins ça c'est bon c'est dans
l'équipe
[Musique]
thorpe aux championnats du monde
un fantasme qui est pour la fesci qui
est l' équipe de france et pourquoi pas
les âmes dauphin
est ce que vous croyez c'est comme ça
vous allez gagner juste participer de
rigoler vous allez toujours et en qui on
va aller courir je peux les habits pour
courir comment on fait
on va chercher la fille qui est en moi
ya pas deux filles m'ont bien sûr que si
abrutis entendra pas des trucs pour
autant au contraire tangara peut-être un
peu
[Musique]
ça veut dire jean paul ange non s'éclate
en passant
[Musique]
drôle
ça m'empêche pas d'avoir peur
imaginez ce qui se raconte autour de lui
mais c'est mon mec et je suis fier de
lui pourtant des filets sur le
on sait que vous avez peur mais on est
là
[Musique]
et puis vous dire aussi que quand vous m